we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p here's a
voicemail that came in let's take a
listen to this hey David I'm a fan of
your show kind of a newer listener but I
was wondering your opinion on how Sean
Spicer has been taking the news of his
quote promotion I usually watch the
press briefings every day and it just
seems like the most recent press
briefing since his announcement of him
leaving as press secretary he just seems
really dejected and like sad and so you
know typically if someone gets a
promotion they're happy they're excited
you know they got a little bit of a
smile on their face but just watching
him a lot of few days it just seems like
he's looking down it's not making a lot
of eye contact he hews this really sad
depressed though yeah yeah this is
something I've been thinking about
because you know we talked earlier this
week about just this bogus claim from
the White House but Oh Sean Spicer has
been doing just so many people's jobs
that we're going to promote him and he's
going to direct White House
communications and you know at a
technical level that's a promotion from
White House press secretary because of
the structure of the organization if
you're doing a good job in such a public
role you don't get removed and put in
the integral where nobody publicly hears
from you anymore it's just it and
clearly this is not a promotion in the
real sense can we start feeling bad for
Sean Spicer I just feel the urge to pity
him a little bit I'm getting closer to
feeling bad for Sean Spicer I admit
we've got a great bonus show for you
today the Supreme Court says no you
cannot ban people from the internet no
matter what they've done I also want to
talk about Stephen Hawking's latest
comment about space exploration we're
going to talk about a major ruling on
police dashcam video and so much more
don't miss the bonus show sign up at
david pakman.com slash membership you
will get instant access to the bonus
show and all of the other great member
benefits if you want a discount off of
your membership pretty good disk I must
say the best discount some might say you
can use the coupon code
I voted 17 when you sign up